you've heard about the Robo games where
robots of various kinds compete to smash
each other grind each other up flip each
other just push each other around the
ring let's take a look at how some of
these machines are made this is UC San
Diego's competitor in the Robo games
it's a 120 pound chunk of steel and
motors called the Kraken and its
distinguishing feature is this plate of
abrasion resistant steel here it's so
hard they had to cut it with a plasma
torch and we're competing in the
middleweight class so 120 pounds there's
also the heavyweight which is 220 and a
super heavy wave so inside we have for
scooter motors we have a 4-wheel Drive
the chains are hidden inside these and
then we have the linear actuator which
basically extends in and out which will
when it pulls back it will pivot the
shield upwards more so it will lift the
shield and the batteries
in the back right here what's your robot
called Oh bad dog bad dog because it
tears things up we get this aluminum
disc with the titanium blade spinning at
about 3500 rpm okay
very scary uh-huh but whatever it hits
it tears into we want an active weapon
because active weapons are so much more
fun to watch writing and then things
like a wedge so rather than defense we
went with wedge is the only design that
really is effective against a spinner
robot because the wedge will just start
skipping across it then the wedge can
Ernie they bring it over to the wall the
spinner will hit the wall and break
itself those bigs mini robots there are
still a few around but not very many
anymore because the widget we show
affected so Marco you're from Brazil yes
from Rio really visionary okay that's
all you've come a really long way to the
Robo games yeah we started competing in
2006 here mobile games I mean it's
really worth it this is store lights
Toro means blowing porches and it's a
lightweight yeah and I still run at
about 6000 rpm and what happens that
when an opponent gets close to it it's
thrown up in the air
so you have to make your robot robust
enough to take big hits fly through the
air six seven feet land on the ground
and still drive that's number one and
then come up with a weapon that you can
try to fight everybody else that's the
hard
you